[Música]
en france 24 es momento de hablar de
ciencia y tecnología soy valentina torre
sánchez y es un gusto acompañarlos en
medio de la guerra en ucrania el
director de la agencia espacial rusa
roscósmos dmitri rogózin aseguró hace
algunos días que las sanciones impuestas
contra rusia podrían hacer que la
estación espacial internacional salga de
órbita incluso cayendo hacia la tierra
para entender esta problemática lo
primero que debemos recordar es cómo
nace el proyecto de esta instalación
conversamos con omar el azkar ingeniero
aerospacial y esto fue lo que nos dijo
nace del fin de la guerra fría y los
gobiernos cultivan o se ponen de acuerdo
y deciden colaborar
en aspectos de investigación espacial y
una del área interesante era poner
estaciones tripuladas en órbitas no
tenía principios bélico no tenía al
principio industrial y ninguna menos
mentalmente científica desde 1984
empiezan a confluir las ideas entre eeuu
y la entonces unión soviética para
llevar a cabo este proyecto conjunto con
el pasar de los años la iniciativa va
creciendo por la necesidad inversiones
mayores y se incluyen otras naciones
esto nos dijo raúl joya ingeniero
mecánico con especialización en
astronomía solamente hasta la
presidencia de clinton es que
definitivamente se le dice a la nasa
bueno ustedes presentan un proyecto más
viable o no y es así que sale la
estación espacial internacional buscando
socios como los europeos los canadienses
y los japoneses y con ese aporte de
dinero que realmente realizan estas
otras naciones y regiones del mundo pues
logran que tengamos la posibilidad de
tener una cooperación internacional para
hacer investigación básicamente esto era
más allá de los problemas políticos sino
simplemente hacer investigación por eso
ahora entonces
podemos contar que desde el año 94
empieza a desarrollarse ya con una
estación bautizada internacionalmente
porque hay colaboración de varios países
en la parte técnica y de construcción de
módulos la estación no fue enviada fuera
de la tierra completa como se conoce hoy
en día de hecho por eso se trata de una
instalación modular en principio tanto
rusia como estados unidos tenían sus
propios proyectos de construir
estaciones en el espacio así que se
aprovechó de lo que se había logrado
hasta el momento en cada nación el
primer módulo fue un módulo ruso que era
de tecnología de los años 90 porque
ellos tenían intención de hacer su
propia estación y se aprovechó todo ese
desarrollo para colocar en órbita un
módulo que implica y lleva todos los
sistemas de soporte para mantenerse en
buenos paneles solares
propulsantes combustibles y sistemas de
navegación entonces ese módulo tiene
capacidad de orbitar la tierra y generar
todos los sistemas y elementos que
pueden hacer que un objeto cumplido por
el hombre se pueda mantener y a la vez
que eeuu creó un módulo menor que sirve
para que apoyado ese módulo se puedan
acoplar distintas naves una vez que
estuvo en órbita todavía estaban
deshabitados no habían astronautas
podían más limpiarse naves dos años
después que tuvo en órbita se manda otra
nave espacial rusa que ya es una
estación espacial tiene capacidad para
albergar dos esperados partir de los
sistemas vitales tiene la capacidad de
generar oxígeno de recitar agua
en el medio carbónico de generar
depresiones acciones y de esa forma ser
habitable y ya con esos tres módulos
podemos decir que el año 2000 se inicia
evitarle la relación espacial es
entonces cuando entran las potencias
occidentales con todos los módulos de
investigación que se han lanzado y
acoplado hasta ahora según lo explicó la
nasa hace poco la estación tiene un
segmento ruso que se encarga de los
sistemas de propulsión y un segmento
estadounidense que se encarga de la
electricidad y los sistemas de soporte
vital por lo que hay una clara
interdependencia la instalación está en
la órbita baja pesa unas 500 toneladas
le da una vuelta a la tierra cada 90
minutos y requiere una propulsión
determinada para mantenerse a unos 400
kilómetros de altura y tienes que
imprimirle una velocidad de al menos 7
kilómetros por segundo para que ese
artefacto permanezca en la altura y si
tú no le aplicas ninguna otra fuerza con
el tiempo al soltar esas partes y
unirlas hacer un solo cuerpo va a entrar
en una caída permanente una pequeña
espiral que si lo acelerará mos
le diría al momento en que toca la
atmósfera y es tocar esa capa de gases
pues decaerá se frenará y se incinerará
y caerá dentro de la superficie
terrestre o el mar pero para evitar esa
caída permanente que es muy lenta pero
que sea hay que aplicarle debe ser de
unos dos o tres meses una pequeña
impulsión hacia la parte superior que se
hace constantemente en medio de la
tensión entre occidente y rusia el
director de roscósmos alertó que si la
estación llegara a caer a la tierra
podría impactar en territorios como
india o china esto debido a la órbita en
la que viaja por lo que no habría un
descenso de los desechos que no se
desintegren sobre rusia para los
expertos es altamente improbable que la
estación caiga y también que el módulo
estadounidense deje de funcionar por
falta de provisiones esto porque ya hay
compañías como spacex que ya desarrolló
su cohete insignia al falcon line y sus
propias cápsulas las dragon con las que
envía provisiones e incluso astronautas
a la estación ahora sobre la propulsión
originalmente se hacía con el módulo
ruso progress este artefacto tiene un
equivalente estadounidense el signos que
se creó con el fin de llevar elementos
pero hace poco se hizo una prueba en la
que demostró que es capaz de propulsar
la estación para que no caiga esto nos
explica el ingeniero en las cara al
respecto no tener que trabajar un poco
más para ponerla a punto y a la vez van
a tener que reemplazarlo los motores del
puente que lo lleva al espacio que en
este momento son rusos y eso es de un
tiempo pero esto lo está haciendo la voz
cierto o sea es cuestión de tiempo los
recursos los tienen lo que pasa que no
es intentar pero sí se puede
perfectamente ha estado unido puede
mantener en un corto plazo de 36 meses
poner en tener tus sistemas logísticos
para mantener un espacio sin embargo los
ingenieros explican que en caso de que
la estación cayera es prácticamente un
hecho que se controlara el lugar donde
impactarían los desechos que no se
desintegren en la atmósfera y se
buscaría que el efecto sea mínimo ambos
coinciden en que rusia de alguna manera
ha reducido su desarrollo espacial por
lo que en caso de que se acabara la
cooperación se vería más afectado no
porque no tenga la capacidad de a estas
tecnologías sino porque los costos al
igual que para eeuu aumentarán
significativamente
así llegamos al final de este espacio a
ustedes gracias por su sintonía
continúen con nosotros en france24
france24 puntocom
[Música]